Kevin final word is here to talk about
zombie first person games dying life we
didn't want to talk about this couple of
weeks ago and you finally got review
code I believe you've played for a lot
of times I've still only get eight
percent what's going on with the stands
of the time I wrote the review in
progress which is up on the site now yes
um because we didn't get the games all
this week so so um you know reviewing
progress up so it killed me because I
played like good 12 hours of it by the
right but I'm I'm really bad at getting
distract it did open world game
sometimes and I hear the fried rice I
things yet and as much as I like in the
last segment I criticized like stuff for
stuff sake dying light is like the
epitome of putting like in for side
activities is putting in stuff for stuff
sake but i keep getting involved in
doing all that is a good stuff some of
it is yes um but then i looked at the
thing um when you first load it up it
says how far you are into the story and
I was like I've played I played 12 hours
eight percent it's like screw you I hate
those things I want them to stop putting
those again I don't want them with more
door was like oh I'm nearly there at the
end and then it said like all you've
done like twenty-three percent I was
like don't tell me that your boiler yeah
most in a way and dying light pulls off
a shadow of mordor it pulls a shadow of
mordor by doing a whole hey that world
that you had oh we're gonna we're gonna
give you another like grace this big
area to do and now here's the second
half it's like oh hi Kenny not the
negative haven't seen the second
investigator on the Holy Well of the
good news is eric has done nothing but
story stuff and so in the story he's
actually further ahead of me already
even though I sounds like that's not
very hard I want to ask you question
Kevin is this a good zombie video game I
don't know if good is the word yet okay
because i feel i feel like if i say now
good i'm guaranteeing a certain a
certain data but so far do i enjoying it
more than that i am enjoying it more
than dead island but i feel it's
important for me to say that I don't
really liked okay that much I'm right
there with them and yet i'm really
enjoying this
has uh you know it has that you know
wonk charm yet it's a classic land ok so
it it does some of the same things like
there's weird behavior and weird
animations and weird clipping and stuff
like that so which kind of has its place
in zombie games i was at least we had
island whenever that stuff happened i
was like yeah whatever zombies adam sure
but all things considered i'm having a
really good time the big thing of course
is the locomotion like you know you're
essentially a train you know it's a say
well well that guy is not really clean
himself up i'll try my mouth a little
bit later because this is one of that
that's one of the most terrifying things
that happens in this game I'll get to
that later I hope but it so does have
the wonk yeah um but it's a lot more and
I hate the word polish because it's such
a meaningless don't use a damn but pick
up dip as opposed to the word walk which
is just which is super clear yeah it's a
clear that place forward on this as a
lot little more cars it it is more
polished than that island arm without
doubt um but at the same time it does
have a little bit of that charming this
job you little weirdo I'm enjoying it
what's the combat missions like yeah um
well combat on when you get into I mean
typically you're actually encouraged to
run whenever you can that's a joy of
having you know of a system of running
where you're essentially playing
Mirror's Edge a zombie game so that's so
that's kind of interesting actually you
can get find yourself in over your head
really really easily cuz you'll you'll
log get the the attention of nearby
really powerful enemies and some of them
are really fast and they will come
running after you and it's like five
stars in GTA like you're just screwed
when that happens you just run and run
and run and you suddenly find yourself
you've run halfway across the map and
still somehow one of them might still be
on your tail so but the coming the
combat itself is like yeah and you know
it's a zombie game it's a it's a tech
land zombie game so there's a paga in
Dead Island they have the the sort of
them like where you hid the zombie would
make a big difference yeah control mode
show some of that also move yet the best
thing is the Dropkick yeah
so you just run if in the jump and boom
with your foot send them flying do you
land on your feet from this traffic or
do you also fall to the ground like
you're some sort of wrestling superstore
you've you kind of fall to the ground
like if you do a dropkick you're
actually vulnerable once the kick is can
we go or a moment oh yeah oh that's too
that's too funny yeah that's the later
it sort of depends on how you do you
could what this is that like a little
hop back movement to ya see right there
you see as I come off yeah heads will
come on you do that I roll please be the
[ __ ] man right into the fire there I see
the scale in there that means that
you've stunned her not that that not
really much and Gregor case fatality um
let me just rub this guy's bits I feel
like I would just hang out on a slope
and wait for all the zombies that come
up with me and just run and draw them
down it yeah and what about nights I'm
so the sort of one of the aspects of
this games as at nighttime they all turn
into 28 days later as zombies in there
like all fast and whatnot due to play
different in lights on you do actually
have to play differently a nighttime so
daytime you're you're typically I mean
sometimes you want certain supplies you
want to just like cut up zombies in the
hope that they have the loot that you
want or sometimes it's just fun there's
a lot of or whatever but you typically
you run you're you're you're staying on
the move you're staying away from them
for the most part at nighttime you stay
away from them but and you do need to
run to do that but you suddenly becomes
more of a stealth game um and the the
powerful enemies that I was talking
about the ones that will like totally
run after you yes they get vision cones
okay and you need to be careful about
their vision cones because they'll see
you they'll start running after you
you'll see me probably get into trouble
in here Dropkick works at my time right
does confirm um but they're a lot more
sensitive to to sound and they will come
after you and start and start chasing
and it does this little mechanic and you
see games before bits really well done
here where you hold a button to look
behind you and what happens is it
there's a little slow mo you look behind
you and they're really fast when they're
on your tail and Mary and I were playing
yesterday for the live stream and I look
back and there's this little
um so yes you have to be extra careful
at night because uh then suddenly you
have you can't just run with uh does
gonna but yeah you have to pay attention
I'm sorry I got you I got stalked by
your own game we were just we were just
talking about the witcher 3 a little
earlier i should try one of the things
we talked about was how finding these
side quests with these stories that are
they're interesting and sort of flesh
out the world of stuff like that so it
did these side quests are they just kind
of like hey we need some metal to shore
up our defenses go get us eight medals
and then you do it or Sara Lee
characters or story and justice becoming
yes to both so there are characters and
stories you play style crane in ten
metal by lorraine Kyle crane who set
who's a government agent set into like
get some some Intel mom and then you end
up having to play the factions in there
who don't know who you are at first they
don't know your [ __ ] right yeah they
don't yet well then they call Ukraine um
you have the voice of Troy Baker even
though the voice which one boy they
really yeah right so it sounds like what
it sounds like your booker dewitt
although i don't know how they got an
actor to do of Troy Baker impression
it's pretty impressive I'd say you can
make my living at your Troy Baker I
patience right now arm so then there's
that and actually I'm kind of into the
story it's pretty simple but I like the
politics of their setting up but then
there is the issue of the missions uh
because and this has been sort of a dead
island thing um you really are just the
the the errand boy of the zombie
apocalypse and it it starts to really
stand out after a while because
everybody's sending you all over the
world and this is the way you get around
there's no there's no like oh now that
I've unlocked this point I can quick
travel there your likes of running
across the map doing alright as y'all
see that is chasing you and those are
the moments that are great but the
missions themselves I mean they get you
out of the world which is good because
it's interesting to go out and do stuff
out there in abundance like themselves
yeah in of themselves it's like you've
got to be kidding me you want me to go
collect this and flip the switch how
many switches have I already flipped for
you in this game like get come on come
up with something new only eight percent
of them according to
yeah but that's all already it's just in
fact he's got this line and he hits on
one of my biggest game pet peeves when
he does this so at some point said that
all these people learn that I'm not just
an errand boy and then it's like okay so
you put in a little bit of dialogue it's
made fun of your own game and called
attention but it but that's it it calls
attention just all the more your side no
I'm doing I like you're still doing its
confidence is so good games it's one of
my pet peeves it's like well why don't
you consider not doing that instead of
actually just poking fun at it in your
dialogue empowered case Pott's resident
zombie errand boy when will the new of
dying light be by and the week I was
thinking oh maybe it'll go up on
Wednesday no no come on rocket app now
much more life switches to flake
apparently lots a switch is that a is
that you get exaggerated metals you want
to get together and do some flick some
switches which lips all we did